hey guys I'm Kelsey cook and I'm the
host of Rissa theory on all things
comedy if you guys have seen the show
before you know I'm a comedian and world
champion foosball player and I bring on
a different comedian every episode to
play me in foosball I basically destroy
them every time it's been fun no you
guys with an ego well no because I'm
already noticing a weak spot in your
game oh my god it also would be fun to
begin his first game without you scoring
a single point it's a lot of fun for me
I really enjoy doing it but this week
we're in Vegas and so I thought we
should go out on the Vegas strip and try
to hustle some people we should trick
people I'm wearing like a titty top and
giant fake eyelashes so I don't think
anybody is going to suspect but I'm a
champion football player and I just want
to go find whatever drunken douchey frat
guys we can and basically ruin their day
maybe take all their money so let's go
see what we can find
[Music]
hey guys so do you mind if I ask you
something really quick I have a web
series where I do things for the very
first time on camera
and so my episode today is about
foosball I've never played foosball
before in Bowl and so there's a table
inside and I just wondered if any of you
wanted to play foosball against me just
real quick you can bring your beers in
and whatever you want
it'll be really fun I'll be really quick
okay what's your name
what Mike and Kelsey Kelsey nice to meet
you okay cuz I've come in everybody want
to come in hey guys
do either of you like playing foosball
yeah it's coming at work called all
things comedy I come on and I do a web
series it's called newbie with boobies
and so I do and thinks for the first
time yeah what's your name sorry to
bother you um have either of you ever
played foosball before are you guys like
going to like strip clubs and stuff you
know what I don't do the strip club I
don't even do the tinder but we actually
look to the cup tonight so that's
awesome
maybe you'll have sex tonight that's
great are you a virgin are you guys
ready
am i are you ready okay welcome back to
pop my cherry I'm Kelsey kook it's gonna
be so fun I'm here today with Ryan and
Nick say hi all right and we're gonna
play foosball for was my first time you
said you played before
yeah in college we had a foosball table
in the basement
wait about that we had to like Pam so we
could spin it around and so oh my gosh
funny and then what about you have you
ever played with a few times at some
local bars and stuff Wow
okay I'm kind of scared of relating I
guess we'll see what happens
okay so surprised if I win if you win
I'll buy you drink okay that good what
if what about if I win it it's up to you
how about 20 bucks you got I got 20
bucks I will demo you then I'll bet you
20 bucks you say you got it okay okay
okay yeah go ahead
oh are you gonna spin it spin it like
don't people spin it yeah yeah okay
that's what that's like illegal but that
will a lot of it oh you got a no joking
he's just joking here we go okay
am I going oh I'm going that way you're
going this way okay here be a little
faster I'm really bad yeah okay how bad
could it be its final very good do you
know the rules should be we should walk
through them real quick tell me what
what are the rules
well basically shoot for the goal throw
in the middle and spin and you try to
just spin it like a [ __ ] yeah yeah
pretty much
that's how I normally do it at least
okay ready I'm just gonna throw it okay
yeah sure oh sorry that's too hard well
then okay these rods it's so funny it's
almost like you feel like you're like
giving like a key or something I feel
like a job that's a pain get off the
table unitard Hey
how about put your goalie Batman smile
I'd probably be just doing yourself a
chance maybe a little bit okay give me
one more point there you go there you go
shoot better I guess there's probably a
defense strategy I don't know I feel
like it's coming to me really quickly oh
[Applause]
my goodness okay
I feel bad what I'm doing how about what
if we play um sucking like a second game
and if you win that I'll buy you two
drinks and you won't owe me any money
you know what I can't go play with that
that's what you want to do
[Applause]
yeah that's so weird I thought I would
never happened
do you guys want to like make a bet or
something like try and make it more like
high-stakes like yes like if if I can
somehow win maybe I buy you guys a drink
or something like a beer sure and if I
win you give me like 10 bucks or
something
are you buy me a drink I'll buy you a
drink of you in sure yeah that's fair
in will buy you two dolly I'll buy you a
drink - you buy you two drinks - drinks
if you wouldn't if you can win do drinks
for two - for two - I'm pretty confident
going into this okay okay ready like I'm
starting to like get the hang of it all
right are you see that hot in this game
it's not on purpose no it's definitely
not on purpose
max ten bucks can I tell you guys
something I'm actually the overall
champion baseball player and I thought
my real voice those are all my baseball
trophies oh yeah see that's what she's
doing she's it for I hate you yep you
are open to it I knew it
can I tell you guys something sure what
so that's not my real voice and I'm
actually a world champion faceoff player
and those are all my trophies and you're
on a web series called wrists of fury
this time overall champion baseball
player okay I totally see that this is
the first time we've ever hustle people
okay okay okay I'm not going to take
your money did you guys think I had
never played before
uh once you had those few goals and I
started kind of thank you for yeah when
you have any of them
and I knew immediately when you're
lining up your shots that you're [ __ ]
yeah well are you put it right here
oh there's if we the fake show is called
pop my cherry you're fine to swear it's
okay oh my god thank you guys so much
for watching first timer newbies with
movies and pop my charity it didn't hurt
nearly as bad as everybody said it would
you guys can follow me online at mommy
okay I can't I can't keep talking like
that you guys can follow me at Kelsey go
call me on Instagram please be sure to
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel on YouTube and watch the rest of
the wrist of fury episodes and we will
see you guys next time bye thank you
guys for watching another episode of
wrist fury be sure to pick up your
official Larisa fury shirts that they
are buttery soft they feel like Dalton
skin they're lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you